sí
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a una nueva edición de
corresponsales tras más de un mes y
medio de guerra en ucrania del mundo ya
comienzan a sentir los coletazos del
conflicto según la organización de las
naciones unidas para la agricultura y la
alimentación fao los precios mundiales
de los alimentos alcanzaron un nuevo
máximo histórico subiendo casi un 13%
tan sólo en el mes de marzo frente a los
precios registrados en febrero
ucrania es uno de los principales
productores de grano a nivel mundial y
la guerra ha perturbado las
exportaciones a través de la región del
mar negro y frenado la producción en
ocho de las nuevas regiones agrícolas de
este país odessa por ahora es el único
lugar que todavía produce el 75 por
ciento de sus cosechas habituales el
reportaje es de etel bonet y diego
ibarra
estas tierras de cultivo por las que
camina olga han sido históricamente
conocidas como la canasta del pan
ucrania es uno de los mayores
exportadores de grano no sólo a europa
sino también a áfrica y medio oriente la
alimentación mundial está en riesgo con
la invasión rusa ucrania pero
la guerra no ayuda a las cosechas ni al
grano es malo para la exportación y para
los cultivos esta tierra provee a
nuestra gente con pan y comida tiene que
continuar en paz y es le sustituyese muy
pronto estar aunque la guerra aún no ha
llegado aquí las consecuencias se
sienten en los cultivos en la producción
tanto a grande como a pequeña escala en
este campo agrícola las cosechas se han
reducido a la mitad por falta de
fertilizantes irrigación y semillas
es muy difícil trabajar estos días
estamos cortos de fertilizantes y
semillas ya que nuestros proveedores
están en la región de kiev y heart son
no podemos transportarlos hasta aquí
flores hurtado y fútbol creen en bolmir
son en esta cooperativa agrícola trabaja
la mitad de sus empleados ya que muchos
se han unido a las fuerzas de defensa
territorial
oleksiy es ingeniero mecánico y ahora el
mismo tiene que reparar los tractores
porque sus mecánicos están defendiendo
las fronteras de odessa
tenemos que estar preparados no podemos
detener la actividad por la guerra
tenemos que seguir produciendo para
seguir alimentando a ucrania de esa sal
de hoy
son nuestros
nuevos
científicos como olga ingenieros y
agricultores como vitalex que no están
luchando en la línea del frente pero sí
están trabajando sin parar en el campo
para garantizar la seguridad alimentaria
o de esa es también uno de los objetivos
estratégicos de vladimir putin
conquistarla le permitiría controlar el
eje logístico entre el mar negro y kiev
pero la urbe cuenta con una importante
ventaja sus catacumbas que ya fueron
utilizadas durante la segunda guerra
mundial más en el siguiente informe
[Música]
los ucranianos conocen bien esta sirena
anuncia la inminencia de un bombardeo y
llama a la población a refugiarse
estos habitantes se resguardan a 20
metros de profundidad en las catacumbas
de odessa unos 2500 kilómetros de
túneles este es alexander quien organiza
esta nueva vida bajo tierra
este tipo de refugio puede soportar una
bomba de una tonelada
esto es lo que los rusos están
utilizando en mariupol en este momento
durante el día son principalmente
mujeres y niños los que allí se refugian
[Música]
todos estamos asustados quién no lo
estaría todos queremos seguir vivos
desde el comienzo de la invasión rusa
los voluntarios como alexander han
estado entregando suministros e incluso
han establecido conexión de internet
para mantenerse informados
no sé si tengo dos libros
hemos aislado las paredes por si tenemos
que quedarnos mucho tiempo
pero esperamos que no
en los últimos días los ataques de los
barcos rusos a odessa han multiplicado
la ansiedad de la población
el domingo vimos las explosiones
estábamos lejos del refugio pero vinimos
corriendo aquí nos sentimos más seguros
no se oyó lo que pasa afuera y los niños
no se asustan lo que me asusta es que
dure mucho tiempo
en caso de un ataque a gran escala las
autoridades tienen la esperanza de que
las profundidades de las catacumbas
puedan salvar la vida de la población
naciones unidas se estima que más de 4.5
millones de personas han huido de
ucrania y unicef denunció que cerca de
dos tercios de los niños de ese país se
han visto desplazados por el conflicto
una cifra que equivale a 4,8 millones de
ellos los menores de edad que ya eran
víctimas de la guerra o que estaban
hospitalizados antes de la invasión rusa
están siendo evacuados de la ciudad
ucraniana de lviv hacia polonia nuestros
colegas de fondo con el reporte
estas familias huyen de ucrania con sus
niños enfermos
en nuestro país de donde somos ya no hay
ningún lugar que acoja a los niños no
hay pediatras y hospitales todo ha sido
bombardeado
[Música]
nuestros la dan a polonia a sólo 85 km
del ivic esta ciudad del oeste de
ucrania la menos afectada por la guerra
se ha convertido en un lugar de tránsito
para quienes buscan refugio en la unión
europea los menores con problemas
médicos pasan por el hospital pediátrico
del ibi pero algunos están muy enfermos
para viajar
hay combates aquí y allá es la guerra no
es posible tratar a los niños en estas
zonas de guerra así que nos los
trasladan
las últimas dos semanas han llegado 400
menores entre ellos este niño de un año
que padece una enfermedad renal su madre
dice que dejó a su marido defendiendo la
capital kiev
debemos cerrar el espacio aéreo a los
aviones de combate no queremos que
nuestros hijos sufran no se merecen esto
toda ucrania está sufriendo esta guerra
qué
en el exterior las ambulancias polacas
llegan para poner a salvo a más niños al
otro lado de la frontera
bajando con chalecos antibalas y en
convoy están evacuando a 240 pacientes
por los cadáveres polonia está aquí para
ayudar
se espera que los próximos días más de
1000 menores lleguen a este hospital
para recibir tratamiento
moldavia es un país de tan solo 26
millones de habitantes emplazado entre
la rumanía y ucrania que se ha
convertido en un ejemplo de solidaridad
y hospitalidad con los ucranianos que
han huido de la guerra sus habitantes se
han volcado a ayudar a los refugiados a
pesar de tener la economía más pobre de
europa tal y como lo reportan entel
bonet y diego ibarra
ha pasado un mes desde que huyeron
terpín pero todavía su hijo pequeño
sigue con pesadillas y tiene miedo de
salir a la calle pero gracias a la
hospitalidad de dima esta familia ha
encontrado no solo un refugio sino un
hogar
nos acabamos de comprar una nueva casa y
nos iban a dar las llaves no sé en qué
condiciones está mi madre y yo estamos
preocupadas pero prefiero no decirles
nada a los niños nada
dimas está acostumbrado a vivir solo
pero ahora que tiene una nueva familia
le gusta pasar parte de su tiempo con
ella y en los días que no llueve y hace
menos frío saca la mesa de comer al
jardín sentí que no estaba haciendo nada
para ayudar a los ucranianos así que
ofrecí mi casa a una familia joven e
intento que aquí al menos pueden hacer
tranquilos que puedan tener su propio
espacio que moldavia está hombro con
hombro con ucrania frente a la invasión
rusa que ha mostrado su apoyo recibiendo
más de 350.000 ucranianos que han huido
de la guerra bolsas de comida ropa
juguetes donados llegan cada día este
almacén de ayuda humanitaria
organizado por un batallón de
voluntarios
al principio recibimos mucha ayuda de la
gente local pero cada vez menos la
situación económica es mala estamos
buscando otros canales para seguir
ayudando a
pequeños gestos solidarios que para
refugiados como tania y olga se
convierten en muy grande
los niños cuando huimos de los
bombardeos en mykolaiv nunca pensé que
íbamos a recibir tanto apoyo la gente
aquí no es rica pero nos dan lo que
tienen bogotá moldavia se ha convertido
en un ejemplo de solidaridad para miles
de refugiados pero a medida que el
conflicto en su país vecino parece
estancarse pone a prueba la economía de
uno de los países más pobres de europa
desde el inicio de la guerra en ucrania
la otan ha multiplicado esfuerzos las
tropas participan en la vigilancia de
los territorios de la alianza
transatlántica a bordo de los aviones
awacs también conocidos como sistemas de
alerta y control aerotransportado
nuestros colegas de fondo y los
corresponsales de france 24 los
conocieron de cerca
son los ojos de la otan en el cielo
aviones como estos utilizan el sistema
de alerta y control aéreo conocido como
awacs este avión en particular se dirige
a ucrania para pasar 10 horas vigilando
la actividad inusual a bordo hay 30
militares de todo el mundo las alertas
son habituales
quiero en belarús acabamos de detectar
un dispositivo de diseño ruso no tenemos
más información de nuestros sensores
está despegando de belarús y se dirige a
rusia podemos suponer que se tratan
potencialmente de tropas rusas
destacadas en belarús que regresan a
casa
y otros operadores de vigilancia
estudian la velocidad la altitud y
concretamente las intenciones de los
aviones que están vigilando
el estudio no se está comunicando por lo
que podría ser de combate u otro tipo de
aviones y nos sigue por lo tanto
procedimientos normales
toda la información recogida a bordo es
altamente clasificada los datos se
cifran y se transmiten en tiempo real a
todos los miembros de la otan la
duración y el número de misiones de
estos aviones se ha duplicado debido a
la duración de los vuelos tienen que
repostar en el aire un proceso delicado
para repostar tienes que poner aviones
pesados uno junto al otro a unos 20 pies
y tienes que mantener la posición de
forma precisa
según rusia la información de obtenidas
se transmite a los ucranianos y se
utiliza en su esfuerzo bélico
desde el punto de vista militar no
proporcionamos información a los
ucranianos la otan sigue manteniendo que
no es parte del conflicto pero no
descarta que algunos de sus 30 miembros
compartan los datos con las autoridades
ucranianas
gracias por seguir un nuevo episodio de
corresponsales nos damos cita la próxima
semana siga con más información en
france 24 y france 24 puntocom